fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby all right let's go now what
are you opening up what is that now you
got a little an energy shot of something
you create them I need something oh
crate them oh great was a little happy
hippo so this is butterscotch oh no I've
never thought of mixing butterscotch
let's go through what you got running
through your system right now you got
some cocaine we got you got you got
stuff you gotta Kratom you're gonna have
you got nicotine
caffeine that's a lot of ends in there
nasal spray nasal spray too yeah my nose
been clogged you got a little coldly
cold no you know how when you have a
cold in your nose club and you keep
using the nasal spray yeah but then then
your body is addicted to it so now
you're using Afrin which is great for
your liver yes what's your I think your
insides right now I'm gonna do your
insides your liver your pancreas
everything's going
but I can't I need help dude give me a
head oh my [ __ ] I'm gonna quit don't
quit dude my insides look like Bill
Cosby is just it's a nightmare yeah it
is it looks like somebody took a torch
to your your whole your your insides
there
um now how what do you figure your life
expectancy is going to be because you're
a big dog
43 what are you on what else are you on
you want testosterone yeah you got off
that I had to oh because I know because
my wiener yep okay so then uh my wiener
now now a lot of times there might be
some alcohol in the system too you know
just not today it's a day cap sometimes
you do a day cap
low grade I say drug addict overall well
I saw I saw a video of us
five years ago we both look very
different oh yeah life will get you oh
life went hey hold on
your voice is even different and your
face is very swollen I couldn't be
whiter grayer I'm an old gray I got a
little gray the pigment your skin kind
of gives up huh yeah I've given up I
mean I'm I'm not I'm I'm an old man and
frankly I'm not attractive and I should
yeah I'm I'm not enough I'm I've never
been my own biggest fan anyway but I was
cuter when I was young Bring It On Life
Bring It On you know the only thing I
can stop I can't stop thinking about is
here's this flowerhorn fish oh [ __ ] what
dude I I'm telling you my parents can I
just tell you my thought just now I'm a
flower you get into your stupid
flowerhorn fish before you get into
these [ __ ] fish because the past four
episodes have been fish heavy man fish
on Fish they've been fish heavy we
haven't even gotten into the salt water
now I do want to hear about it I don't
know a lot has happened for my birthday
I do want to hear I don't I had a
thought this is a [ __ ] up thought
I thought to myself you're going to get
to a point where you're a bit decrepit
and maybe then I leap from this chair I
jump on you and beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out that's all this I'm killing isn't
that [ __ ] up no that's how this show
ends oh [ __ ] I want to bring the hand
grip thing yeah squeeze the hanger yeah
but I I just said you guys a hold of
that hand grip this flower horn I'm
thinking about
I hate to keep going back I feel like
you just bringing it back there there's
an eight inch flower horn the one of the
most aggressive no no water fish nobody
covered that but look at them no no I
know does he have a big old brain yeah
yeah there's but there's one I've been
got a big old herpes sore on the [ __ ]
top of his head he's eight inches he's
he's by himself yeah I cleared out the
tank I'm Gonna Leave This Jack Dempsey
in there with him and two kind of larger
Oscars you're gonna let him fight it out
no no they're not gonna fight if they're
big enough to withstand that headbutt of
his they're gonna survive really and if
they don't
how does homeboy eat without getting his
head in the way
great question and what the [ __ ] is in
that head
it must be just dude I've been thinking
about it since 3am I woke up thinking
about this flower horn I see him in
there he Brams the tank I'm like I need
that thing in my life I'm gonna clear
out these other fish the tank is big
enough 75 gallons right so he's like
gallons Daddy has a new filter in there
because he's gonna make a mess I mean
you know this he's gonna make a mess
I didn't know that are they sloppy
eaters sloppy eaters I want to write
this stuff down wait give them time
don't get the viewers time to write this
down I know you guys wanted to hear
about flowers very sloppy eater there's
Just Fish everywhere okay it's just a
real mess you got to feed him feed him
flakes bro flakes yeah are you from
1997. fish don't eat flakes I don't know
you know I fed you know what I fed my
puffers this morning what live Krill
Live Crew and hey yeah give him the show
why say that come to the show when I
drop them Krill in there I need a video
um I need to start doing some fish
videos
see a lot of fish emails
hundreds now people they keep asking me
they want to send me fish I don't know
how I feel about that what hey chin look
up the most expensive fish oh some of
those flowerhorns get up to
1200 bucks 1500 bucks that I'm looking
at you can buy for your aquarium no this
this Charles Manson flowerhorn I'm
thinking about the fish store since 3am
I can't emphasize so you're so you're
obsessing the way you obsess of a car
Brian I want to wrap this podcast up
right now so I can rush to the fish
store and get that big flower it's so
weird so aggressive hold on the Asian
arowana oh they're so
first of all they get this big hold on
1500 bucks hey minimum this big buddy
hey albino specimens have sold for
seventy thousand dollars
man these someone costs 400 000. click
on them chin hey B don't get this big
leave me that big dude you need a big
tank huh what do they eat yay you like
the sound of chirping crickets what
that's a snack you [ __ ]
with
dude my fish tank so you can't my fish
tank yeah it's it's it's it's it's a
prison yard dude so you survival you
can't put your your Arrowhead I mean you
can't put your flower horn in there with
anybody but somebody his own size
correct otherwise he'll eat them and
kill them if anybody's smaller it's like
polar bears boom you can't put something
smaller you can't put a smaller polar
bear in a polar bear cage at the zoo
because they could eat of two juvenile
Oscars that I'm a little worried about I
think I'm gonna transfer them to my to
my son's tank which is 60 gallon not
small not small and I'm gonna have them
you know and then when they're a little
bigger and put them back into the prison
cell
so you got now four tanks gone I have
three and the salt water is Gonna Come
the salt water's coming on your bird and
salt water you know what's gonna happen
when Daddy gets so no I don't me neither
no I don't think he's okay I'm scared no
no I understand I like your uh your
necklace your necklaces these are the
thick boy Awards we give out Awards okay
they just came in do you want one I do
you gotta earn it well how do I earn it
with not stupid MMA knowledge do I have
I don't have to gain weight no no no I'm
not a hard boy though no fixing the
heart I don't know about that yeah
that's our slogan fixing the heart our
boy Tara kazim came to visit me that's
my guy and and he's he's sent me a nice
video he's been lifting weights he's
been going heavy Daddy's jackets he gets
so thick he's a [ __ ] tuna fish with
feet
he's just he's a bluefin he's a blue fin
tuner with feet he's as thick as it gets
oh cause Jim brought up Santino's new
specials on Netflix best special to see
all year even though we're 12 days into
the year but it'd be tough to beat this
one good friend every venue I've gone to
I was asked who was here how was their
set and you know the managers to tell me
for the past I'd say two years every
venue I go to across the board who has
the best set Santino who's the best set
who else have you had in there the
biggest names you know every single
manager goes Santino wow best step we've
seen in years wow that's this special I
can't wait shout out to Santino I can't
now
we thought I was gonna come and find the
kid now he's doing Rogan right now I
said hey I thought you're coming I'm
doing Rogan on it okay well just same
just as good as ours I get what you're
doing there it's a little bigger just
the same same show same same reach okay
same reach all right same reach okay
same Bridge
now I posted a throwback uh animation of
us on Rogan
you forget how much [ __ ] we've done dude
a lot too much a lot we've done a lot
buddy it's been okay hasn't been posted
yet or refresh it Tim
go ahead and refresh
thanks okay just never got posted that's
okay okay that's okay well you know nice
yeah what can you do we got sigura and
and us look at that way back in the day
oh we're gonna ask you if you're on a
Johnny Carson yeah awesome teaching okay
hey B let's take a little break because
you need to catch playing to Fort Wayne
Indiana I'm gonna be there this Friday
Saturday Packers next weekend continue
Florida Danny improv Packer fans know
you're depressed get out of depression
go see Brian Cowan you're just a hop
skip jump away and to get to Fort Wayne
and then I'm in Tampa Tampa is next or
Friday Saturday only the 20th and 21st
Tampa Improv Tampa Bay just dust off
those Steve Young rookie jerseys get
your ass down there Tampa Improv the
week after I'm sorry in the next state
Spring Field uh was that Missouri
Springfield Missouri yep the blue room
or something like that February third
and fourth Naples Bakersfield's on there
Brea March 3rd and fourth get your
tickets at thickboy.com also tiger thick
sweet nectar award-winning actors
available at all shows now you brought
the impression I did and this episode is
brought to you by Better Health that's
right yes dude mental health is
something that you know people always
Overlook but it's something you have to
take care of the way you take care of
your body you brush your teeth in the
morning sometimes you don't have anybody
to talk to I know as a guy that's one of
the things I don't have friends I can
talk to guys don't deal with it that way
okay but sometimes to have a licensed
therapist you can talk to virtually or
on the phone or whatever this is where
better help comes in yep and if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option I've used it
multiple times especially lately my
therapist is like okay again uh it's
convenient flexible affordable and
taught entirely online all you gotta do
is just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge so if you want to live
a more empowered life therapy can help
you get there visit betterhelp.com
fighter today get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp health.com
you're talking about licensed
professionals who are experienced in
helping you in ways you probably aren't
aware of so give it a shot don't deal
with with it on your own man there's
somebody to help you out there
betterhelp.com fighter 10 off better
help well let me let me give you this
little reminder okay best supplements on
planet Earth on it okay now sure here's
the thing you want to see your New
Year's resolutions through with on its
New Year all you does it helpful new
year new me well what if I told you
there's freaking 20 off all right
supplements select supplements about
Fitness 50 digital items like this
they're streaming Fitness
some of the best they're they're half
hour classes which are unbelievable yep
and for training you can do at home join
the on it challenge the New Year all you
on at six challenge it's a six week
workout program and lifestyle program
with over 36k in prize money 36 000 yep
the challenge helps you connect with
others at the honor community so you can
support each other achieve your goals
you know rah-rah you got cheerleaders so
fun time that's right on it.com slash T
nope uh Slash f-a-t
-k there you go Jesus Christ audit.com
slash f-a-t
-k yep that supplements Best Fitness
Gear on the planet audit.com
f-a-t-k get you some
yeah if you're in uh Johnny Carson so
ridiculous
yeah
now B you're gonna fly around the world
right to get to uh
Fort Wayne Savages
um you're gonna fly around the world
yeah I am
now Fort Wayne you've seen stranger
things right Indiana think of stranger
things yeah
nothing happened so yeah so imagine
watching stranger things and they just
chilling it's a quaint little town I
like it you know every every Everything
is a quaint little town until a stranger
comes to visit now you're the stranger
the stranger can be somebody who's about
to put out some power with comedy or the
stranger can be a guy with a knife
is it rained a lot nope why is the power
out Brian counts it that's right that's
right he's doing comedy in the dark and
by the way Fort Wayne Indiana when I
land you'll feel it you know I ever tell
you I had that um when we landed in New
Orleans New Orleans no and the uh flight
attendant so funny you just get we
landed in the flight attendant goes oh
he was this very very handsome if I
remember correctly black gentleman who
probably had been a dancer
and he goes he goes we land and he goes
he goes oh y'all feel that
that's New Orleans right there I was
like this bad [ __ ] I was like ah
was that when you were there for uh
doesn't pourri
in fact it might have been back no I
know what it was when I went to shoot a
movie there oh remember you and I did uh
New Orleans House of Blues remember that
post man-made the voodoo post yes yes I
also remember us going and seeing some
weird Voodoo [ __ ] in some of those
stores that was on me yeah yeah there
was somewhere like a uh a dream catcher
a human skull Well w w e b Dubois who
was a black uh scholar and leader and
Visionary and and all that stuff and a
writer
um in the 60s I believe it's the 60s he
became somewhat radicalized because in
the south
he went down to the South and he was
from I think originally the West Indies
Highly Educated spent his time in New
York in the academic circles literally
and he went down to the South I think in
the 50s or even the 60s before the Civil
Rights Act was passed in 64. and what
radicalized him was in a store window he
saw body parts that's the [ __ ] I want
body no black body parts that were like
teeth and all that stuff that were for
Voodoo reasons no just uh oh wow just
just this [ __ ] the level of racism
that he experienced and the murderous
racism and it it literally changed his
went South I thought I thought we were
talking about Voodoo
oh because she says New Orleans I said
deep voodoo voodoo it's got deep voodoo
that's why like I always feel like I
love New Orleans but when the Sun goes
down and then and then the night takes
on that that late night flavor see what
happens is the smile comes in well you
guys all Everybody Plays around
everybody's playing around they're all
doing their thing let's go to dinner
nice dinner let's go to Bourbon Street
get a couple drinks tits and Voodoo yeah
get a couple drinks I don't know then
what happens is when when the clock
strikes 12. there's a whole another
under tapestry the underworld comes out
that's where I come out yeah that's
where I come alive yeah and there are
places that open up nobody knows about
lest you're on a list yeah and you got a
party now Beignets and tits Potter can
be all kinds of things Beignets and tits
could be a little devil worship might be
a croc in that house could be a croc or
an alligator could be a could be a one
of those huge [ __ ] rats that live in
the bayou called the Yovan nutrient a
nutria could be
could be the Obama with a new tree on
our leash you never know
you know
could be a lot of things but I love New
Orleans oh yeah no I could see it now
I'm thinking about man I didn't get back
down because I have that the the haunted
tour too I like I love that [ __ ] well
you know Nolan Nolan's is is got a place
for all ages and all types you
understand it's weird about New Orleans
though so many great Comics come out
there's not any great venues because you
think Ellen's out of there it's weird
Mark Norman Theo yeah it's weird a few
more Midnight in the Garden of Good and
Evil they made a movie about it but it's
a book oh it's a good book and it's
about New Orleans you ever seen Princess
and the Frog I didn't about New Orleans
I didn't know that great movie no little
June bug
okay
you got it watch what's this bring it up
you remember this
ah
dumb I tell the story about Kimbo Slice
Kimbo Slice I'm Ultimate Fighter yeah
when you guys were doing that they
didn't even show this on the air so this
guy I'm not gonna mention his name on
the show he lost and you can drink all
that alcohol you want in the house and
there's only at the time there's only
four of us left still fighting Roy
Marcus Jones matrione myself that's the
four fighting right so one of you guys
one of the other guys is hammered
hammered wasted
all of a sudden this guy gets super
racist in the house and there's a bunch
of black guys in the house starts
throwing up racial slurs and throwing up
these you know the hit hey Hitler stuff
Heil Hitler stuff write his name on this
piece of paper
all right the stuff all right I have the
big biggest fight of my life the next
day and I thought it was a dream Kimbo
Slice and Marcus Jones and this and this
D'Amico in this D'Amico Rogers uh comes
in my room and they go yo shop get up
dog get up man I'm like huh why is there
three large black guys around my bed Kim
goes yo man this dude's down there
talking about our people we're about to
Jack him up I literally I thought I was
in a dream I go excuse me talking about
our people dog let's go F this dude up
I'm like listen uh you guys realize I
said I'm not down with the race thing
but you realize I'm not black right Kim
goes you ain't black
damn that's crazy
turn around leave and I hear that's why
Lock Shop you can't tell what the hell
he is
that's a great story old school [ __ ]
that's a great story Good Times old
school great animation oh yeah poly tune
I think right now with chat GPT you can
do your own animation that'd be nice
from what I hear hey you know it's been
around for a hot second it would chat
gbt or whatever didn't it wasn't
November 30th 2022. it's been around for
like years I guess no no no no no the
actual open AI for the public chat for
the people yeah so so that's so funny is
that my buddy's attacking investigation
Jay was like I go I go this chat GPT and
he goes I got a text he goes hey man is
it 2019 yeah
hey dumbass we've known about this for
years
guys have been using it it's Johnny come
lately to the train I'm Johnny come
lately my buddy goes no no it's not
going to take over the world it would
have done it already right it's been up
for a hot I was all [ __ ] up yeah I was
all [ __ ] up should we go to New
Orleans
Nolan's
nons be good dude should we book a fire
kid live in New Orleans I think that's a
good idea it's not a bad idea yeah I
think it's a good idea I'm a fire enough
I'm fighter fired up for this year yeah
me too I'm fine get back to some [ __ ] I
like your shoes very loud very loud but
not so much actually I don't mind the
off-white these shoes are made for
running and I'm gonna run out of here
and get that flower horn because all I
can think about that's all you're
thinking and I'm gonna drop them off
like litter this is in the way of your
flower oh it's like but you already have
a flowerhorn I don't oh you don't he
passed away from the white ick not on my
terms for in the in so I go to pick him
up yeah yeah and I go there's white
spots on the his white egg oh that's not
good it should only be a couple days to
come pick them up I go in yesterday to
buy uh uh clams half half shell clams
because the puffer fish eat half shells
you need clams now it's exhausting I
made a mistake anyway anyway hold on
they're exhausting so you you put the
clams in there and they open up half
shell because you need the and then you
leave two shells in there because
they'll bite the shells to to clean
their teeth it's a nightmare so you're
out there don't tell me any of this
you're getting fresh Krill all right
you're getting hey hold on every day I
have to stop by and pick them too much
20 of food a day you do the math no it's
too much and my son today he was all
excited I mean it's just my thing now
basically but he has a dope tank in his
room but I go hey buddy you ready to
feed the fishes hey Dad he'll give like
just stay here this morning
oh yeah oh no I can feed him yeah I saw
it I'll handle it yeah he's done he's
done you know kids are done with that
daddy's not though
I want to know how long until you are
done but my guess is you might become a
major collector and become totally
irrational my dad will warn Joanna
because she was like hit him in these
[ __ ] fish man he goes have you not
met Bren oh when he gets into something
he gets all the way and he goes this
isn't gonna stop he probably has a shark
down there yeah yeah yeah you you sure
do you know Brad you get crazy oh dude I
don't know why why you don't have the
ultimate in
octopus oh no we've already talked about
it too my birthday's in March okay if
you don't think last night I was
researching octopus to buy on the dark
web you're out your mind what octopus
you gonna get I can't decide and the
puffers and the saltwater puffer you can
get out of control really out of control
you know that in in Japan you will eat
puffer fish it's all good and they all
know that there is a certain puffer fish
that you'll you'll when you when you
ingest the meat you die so it's always
still eat it they still eat it flat cut
they're exactly right you'll die my papa
ate that when he was in the Navy Jesus
and out there he was stationed in Japan
yeah in the Navy he hasn't ate sushi
since he's like whatever 22. yeah he got
sick from eating puffer fish wow so he
says I don't know if I buy it this is
the guy I know Dad do you just not like
sushi or it wasn't puffer fish he just
had bad Sushi that's what I told him
yeah so you sure it was puffer because I
feel like you're hating on my puffer
fish right now yeah
um
I want you to be invested into my fish
life I'm not going to can you survive
puffer fish poison let me see what that
says
three of the patients had severe
symptoms
yep but no one died puffer fish contain
a potent neurotoxin now let's not go bad
on my puffer fish this is a certain kind
of puffer the ones I have are very cute
and harmless but if you do back from the
corner the puff on you whoa but really
they don't have toxins though but
they're puff on you what do they do they
just puff up and now they get spines
this can get prickly it's gonna hurt but
I asked the guy yeah he goes you got to
make sure they don't buff up like a
wagos it's so strenuous on their body
and stresses them out yeah so dude
they're so fun now let me ask you this
when uh hey come the show now now hey
6am you gotta know this your octopus are
very smart now we have video of an
octopus going coming climbing out of the
cage out of its own aquarium
crossing the living room floor climbing
up into the other aquarium eating a fish
going back into it you know this yes I
know this that's how you want there do
you know something else about I want
that life they can see your face and
they know whether or not you're angry or
you're not and they can also touch you
and feel if you have if you have the
intention to kill them or hurt them let
me see that and you [ __ ] eat
calamari you're disgusting they only
live about a year disgusting they only
live a year though right calamaris no
they live forever Brian look at this
travels down the drain TV setup oh my
god oh that's the plot of Nemo what the
[ __ ] case solved that's the plot of Nemo
he gets out and goes into the seed later
[ __ ]
Mike see I want this challenge though I
like how they have the big nuts for the
back of the head you know what though
they're too smart to keep as captives
they might want to be out there but they
don't get eaten you know how good I'd be
to that thing sure
I'll say their name later they're like
oh she's gonna buy those fish and then
you can put them in a tank for your
amusement I'm like hey [ __ ] it's either
that or they go to into the sea and get
eaten alive
yeah night time is tough today I pet
three Oscars they count to tank a hand
fat them blood worms I'm feeding them
blood worms Brian they're eating like
it's not not a bad it's not a bad life
to be a shop these little [ __ ] these
little slimy scalysis shop to puss they
won the lottery
hand fed one one y'all one of y'all
gonna be a shop to puss might might get
too sharp to puss chin bring up uh uh
octopus for sale hey guys I'm sorry that
we keep making this about fish but I'm
I'm a little I'm just fascinated with
your fascination oh not fish but I'm
just fascinated with your fascination
that's what I'm gonna do I'm Gonna Leave
Here Right can we end it early I'm Gonna
Leave Here I'm gonna get that flower
horn yeah I'm gonna take a video of it
this thing is so gnarly looking yeah it
will give you nightmares really it is
the Charles Manson of fish octopus man
200 that's crazy 200 how can you afford
not to get that thing and be comfortable
that's crazy it's hard not to look at
the one with the big [ __ ] the one
that looks like he has uh dreads like
you know the rest of fire engine that's
how cute I'd get attached to my octopus
my Oscars dude Larry Kevin and Frank
Larry Kevin Frank are called what will
you get two octopus so they can be
friends I see that's a it gets a little
dicey when you mix them really I think
so what happens if they ink things up
oh that's a squid brown white spots and
they are in a neutral mood the body of
the octopus is covered with whatever
allows you to blend in any background
that's what they're they're Shape
Shifters
oh wow here's my thing I'll get a a big
tank let's say 150 gal we'll call it a
gal gallon for you lameos I'll get 150
gal I'll I'll I'll stash that thing just
put I'll switch a coil and just half the
octopus how big is it 150 gallons 150
it's a lot that's what I'm daddy for his
birthday was that a bathtub size
[Music]
for an octopus and you're in Daddy's
Hand feeding we're shaking hands every
morning what you want to live what you
want to live you're gonna be touching
the octopus oh do I get my hands on my
wash my hands and then I'm telling you I
pet I pet my Oscars be this ain't
something I just stare at the fish we
have a real deep connection dude you
give him a pat down oh yeah yeah rock
hard yeah crazy huh what yeah I'm fish
crazy yeah you fish crazy oh dude some
people are caught crazy some people come
crazy some people fish but what's
interesting about it is dude the the
chemistry of mixing certain fish with
other fish they will kill each other be
so you there's only one way to find out
it is a prison yard you seen Shawshank
yeah I got ladyboys in that tank I got
red in that tank I get Andy Dufresne I
got the warden and you're looking at
them yeah these are aggressive [ __ ]
fish man look at that best top five
Oscar fish
eating Predator at the office see that's
a big Oscar that was fast now his name
how fast it is you have no idea be
holy [ __ ] nutsos
how the [ __ ] is he getting him that fast
because they're gangster I mean small
they don't even know what the [ __ ] hit
him
so my Oscars are they're juveniles but
they can get that big and they also
stripe like that beautiful fish I have
an albino one too I call them Whitey and
uh Kevin I come Kevin the trash man
because Kevin the trash man yeah and uh
shot to the garbage boys named after the
are you garbage boys Kevin the trash man
you better get your food you better get
your food otherwise he'll eat it all
well that goldfish dude I can feed him
frozen peas Brian what yeah dude they
need veggies too whoo my Oscar
frozen peas dude I gave him they're like
the coyotes of the water guys I'll give
them liquid IV bro I'll give them
athletic greens right now these are
coyotes in the water but he don't give a
[ __ ] coyotes have been known to eat
fruit I might they adapt hey I might dab
a little happy hippo into that tank it's
eating a salamander Bros that's not
right bro that's a baby that's a gecko
that's a full-size gecko that's the
geckos slap into the tank because they
can't swim you're seeing gekko's hands
poor thing can't even breathe
he's just sitting there hey Oscars are
gangster this Oscar has half a [ __ ]
gecko in his mouth
what's going on in that gecko's head oh
well better luck next life
yeah
oh now he's getting selfish
wow oh yeah life eats life somebody's
going through if you're a vegan what
happens how when you plow a field how
many animals you have to kill every
snail every vole everything every weasel
every rabbit yeah I don't know all the
all the uh even the groundhogs even The
Fawns that that everyone so you kill
everything when your machine feels
that's why the birds follow those
[ __ ] machines then you gotta poison
the [ __ ] out of everything so you can
lay fertilizer because you got to get
rid of all the weed I hate to be extreme
here but I don't eat fish anymore
that's [ __ ]
super annoying this is gonna know you
too no I'm hey hey you order calamari
around me especially after I get an
octopus named Eddie you if you [ __ ] with
and you eat uh uh Eddie affiliate of
mine
I'll I'll fight you this is so annoying
to me like if Sasso ordered that that
black squid calamari that he ordered at
scopa yeah so you won't eat cod you want
anything no no no no no no no no no no
no no how can I how could I
you're so [ __ ] annoying would you eat
a flowerhorn
yeah I would in front of you I'll eat
anything in your [ __ ] tank you know
now you know flower horns aren't uh
natural they're not natural fish I don't
care they're a hybrid I'll fillet and
eat it and then you know what I mean the
ball the bulbous I'll I'll fillet it and
I won't eat it I'll be like I'm not
hungry after I got it all filet and
lemoned up
yeah lemon and parsley hey you know me I
like a good joke right yeah stop right I
like you I'm fun right I'm fine yeah hey
stop why
because I have fish now man it's
different I'll eat your fish you might
as well say you can eat my kids
I'm hungry
I like to say you know me I have fun
time right Fun Time Charlie yeah talk
about fish yeah it ain't fun really it's
not funny to me what are you an Oscar
and I'm a goldfish is that what's going
on oh you're a guppy buddy I'm a guppy
piece of [ __ ] guppy that I feed my
Oscars and I'm an Oscar huh you're not
an octopus bro I can use my legs do
average uh [ __ ]
man Cooks needs flowerhorn he said it
was delicious too well why would you
bring that up delicious that looks like
[ __ ] dude it looks delicious and I got
something for you by eating a cichlid or
a flowerhorn you're actually saving
other fish because last time I checked
they eat all the other fish
yeah that's what Ben you know Ben
Franklin was a vegetarian and he was on
a boat on his way from the the colonies
to [ __ ] England and they were cooking
uh fish up on the boat with butter he
was starving he was living on biscuits
and [ __ ] like you know back then
you're a vegetarian fattest vegan ever
correct and he was he was dying he was
like God that smells so [ __ ] good he
just wanted a butter oh so he's sitting
there and he goes but I'm a vegetarian I
gotta stick to it then he sees them open
one of the fish and a bunch of fish fall
out of it because the thing had just
eating a bunch of fish and he goes wait
a minute
if I eat that fish I'm saving fish
and that's how he got off his
vegetarianism and ate all you know he's
a nudist too he'd walk around town he's
a character yeah
yeah kind of a celebrity in France kind
of a big time had so many girlfriends
straight up girlfriends and friends oh
yeah girlfriends yeah fattest brilliant
brilliant chub chub now did they find
dead bodies in his basement sure well a
lot of vegans uh if they don't do it
right they tend to they tend to eat a
very carb remember when I went vegan for
a week yeah I ate all the carbs yeah the
hummus hummus yeah well a lot of like so
a lot of uh like people from India when
they live on chapatis and and Dal and
and they eat like rice that kind of a
heavy carb thing you get what they call
Deli belly and you'll just get like a
belly you know it's just it's it's you
can't just if you're gonna do vegetables
you got to do it right it's all right to
the point that's why I don't eat fish
anymore well Daddy eats nuts some nuts
berries these nuts [ __ ] [ __ ] how about
my 11 year old son my 11 year old son
goes he goes hey man what's this Dragon
thing man I go Nick is in the car I go
Dragon he goes yeah dragging these nuts
across your face I go I'll [ __ ] kill
you he's 11 years old then he because
he's allowed to swear around me and he
knows some [ __ ] and uh and he goes can I
say [ __ ] and I go yeah within context
you know and he goes no because I'm not
allowed to still tell my son if it's not
me he can say and then so I say
something he goes he goes
he just he goes hold on let me just
check something oh there are zero [ __ ]
in here so I can give zero bucks and I
go I started laughing because hold on
let me call the [ __ ] store they just
closed they just closed so they don't
have any [ __ ] either I was dying I was
like dude you're a [ __ ] cop well it's
like when we're in the Green Room uh
David asked me something and I I was
like what I thought I heard him say it
before and I guess Jay said it and he's
like uh what do you think of these and
he said something with D's in it and I
was like yeah D's Nuts he's like that's
why you guys are brothers your brother
said the exact same thing I was like
we're mature man I I'm sorry I shall
laughed his girlfriend me and my friend
had this whole thing where he'd be like
he tried to get me to say these because
these you know these uh you know Dee
Smith I go D's who and he goes Deez Nuts
[ __ ] what would Jake is you know
he eats like a group of fish he'll [ __ ]
all over his mouth and teeth all I have
to say is hey you know Dwight it's like
the Dwight around your mouth you know
Dwight I'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah my grandmother my grandmother
my dad's side used to get they like
Oscars here yeah disgusting what's the
white some people get that
um Elliot Spitzer the I think it's him
or no no no no no Michael avenatti I
mean that guy is now in jail remember
the lawyer Michael Avenue yeah he was
like you know they were uh he takes on
Trump he might be the next president
Nike yeah well he tried to extort Nike
and he he's doing a lot of times 14
years holy [ __ ]
I mean he was on top of the world but
when he would talk he would get this
saliva on he knew he used to represent
uh summer dancing stormy yeah I guess he
took money from her I guess he took
money from his clients I mean 14 years
well she he did the book deal for her
and she was like he never paid that's
crazy take money that's crazy yeah
apparently he was stealing money from
his clients like I always thought he was
pretty uh pretty cool like he seemed
like he was on top of the world kind of
a badass then you find out it's like
dude you're you're being a criminal and
then when he went after Nike like he was
like we're trying to extort Mike Jordan
he tried to extort Nike yeah dude we
make off-white Air Force Ones I mean 14.
he's a lawyer too 14 years dude think
about that your life is done
sentence of 14 years for a fraud scheme
stealing millions of dollars from
clients are you kidding
how do you how are you that dumb and
that immoral is to pay over 10 million
in restitution to four clients under the
IRS
hey what do you think you're just gonna
get away with being a [ __ ] idiot
adventure's Gonna Catch You right people
do the dumbest [ __ ] like that you see
they they just you're looking and you're
like did you think you're ready like
this guy Santos this [ __ ] Republican
Congressman on his resume the guy said
he went to Baruch College in another
College he never went to those colleges
he said he was Jewish he said I'm Jew in
yeah that's later but he said as a proud
American Jew that every Jewish
organization was like hold on what the
[ __ ] my your grandmother died when he
said my grandmother died in 911 she died
in 2016. the lies are so crazy you see
him in the first just got voted in it
like it's all good well they found out
later you see this now they don't know
if that's his real name do you see him
throwing up the the white supremacist
yeah I don't know I don't know if that
was if that was like I don't know if
that was the case but this [ __ ] idiot
is sitting there in Congress he was
alone just on his on his phone he looks
like a group of fish nobody else is
heavy on fish right now but how the [ __ ]
do you what up who voted for that I mean
well nobody everybody thought he would
he wasn't nobody thinks you're gonna lie
like tell Tulsi gabbard goes have you no
shame don't give a [ __ ] he didn't work
for Citigroup no or for going south city
did no Wall Street nothing well that's
debatable and they're being nitpicky no
they're not well I like the those the
schools he said he went to of the alumni
like what years were you there wow
that's like when we have friends you
know really your friends when they're
like yeah I'm a brown belt or black belt
in this I'm like wait from who well and
they tell us why was there during those
years he goes oh we must have just
missed it no no no no no no no no
there's no ways to check this there's
four big guys you would have been in the
group I meant yeah there are ways to
check that out yeah my mother knew a guy
like that who uh he was he was working
with my father and the guy said um well
I used to play it I played in Wimbledon
as a tennis player they all loved tennis
he goes I played I played at Wimbledon
so obviously wimbledon's like you if you
played at Wimbledon Wimbledon you're
like saying I played basketball have you
ever seen how good those guys are the
guys who you don't even know of when you
watch them play you're like it's also
you have to be a part of a club like you
and I if we're like Hey we're gonna play
tennis we fly to England no no this guy
played in Wimbledon in other words like
you know top ranks yeah when you're
either anybody's ever played in
Wimbledon is so good you can't believe
it like like they're just 100 in the
world yeah I mean it's ridiculous they
hit the ball so hard everything else
it's grass and he he gets out on the
court and couldn't hold the racket like
he was hitting the people earlier and
and my mother goes this guy's crazy and
he goes I'm a little out of practice
and my mother said we had you have to
talk to he can't work he's crazy yeah
then he said the same thing about golf
same thing he was hitting the ball why
do guys lie about this well I think some
people are [ __ ] crazy or there are
such narcissists they think they can get
away with being that way
like okay nor does that one the thing is
like fibbing
like or or you knew I joked like when I
was joking around I saw that mountain
lion you guys called me out that was
funny or like you with whatever I knew
you were alive I was like you [ __ ] I
started laughing no I've seen mountain
lion yeah I go I'm asking again but this
remember that one guy who came in our
lives I want to see who it is but he was
like yeah I thought chick Congo and
remember that time I was fighting he's a
high five chair Congo I fight vanderley
Silva I'm like oh well I can just Google
the records I remember that and remember
what you said to me oh you go I'll do it
right now yeah well I'm doing it on the
phone I knew it's [ __ ] and then I
was like this never happened and then I
go uh what I say and then I go oh well
it's weird man I looked up the records
your name's not on any of their uh
record books yes it wouldn't be on there
that it was uh on the beach not
sanctioned fight so on the beach we
fight Jake Owen for Android Silva on the
beach yeah man yeah yeah okay well I
can't source that so yeah people are
that there's that becomes a habit I
don't know what that's about like I I
oh I told the story on uh I was on the
radio and I told a story about domestic
uh to impress domestic violence uh where
I saw a couple in a fight and then the
cop came to break it up and the woman
jumped on the cop's back now I told the
story like you were there and yeah I'm
there and then I said and she fish
hooked him and everybody in the in the
in the everybody in the [ __ ] thing
went oh my God and I went and I go I go
well that's not true I go I might have
made up the fish hook part because it
just makes the story better yeah and we
will do that but I had to stop myself
because I was like hey hey you can't
tell a [ __ ] don't do that I can get
away with it but don't do that on a
[ __ ] radio but it was very funny I'll
add I'll add you know but I I don't
actually think I actually don't think I
add
um I think I'm pretty good about not
adding stuff at the end of the day I
think that's just a bit on stage can
exaggerate yeah but if I if I'm gonna
tell a story about a fight that I saw or
was in I'm not gonna add an an extra
punch
I'm just not no I'm not I hope not it's
if you do it out of you're joking I'm
not going to add anything about like I'm
not gonna pad my high school wrestling
record yeah I'm not going to do that but
there are people that do this weird [ __ ]
all the time yeah you didn't ask him
it's like what are you talking about
dude yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
it's very strange yeah
yeah
um
I think that sometimes hey do you want a
flowerhorn
no no no but thank you oh yeah no you
got flower horn on the brain bro
what's going with your hair you got a
little cap you you just decided to be
stylish you know you know I feel like
doing my hair cute daddy's been up since
four
that's awesome uh I was thinking about
the flower Hornet three fell back to
sleep Boston at 4 30 goes Daddy I'm
awake and I'm wet that means he pissed
his uh jammies yeah cutie pie my my
little boy's sick so he's nothing worse
hacking nothing worse hacking not
sleeping through the night no nothing
more hacking hurting waking up like hey
babe I'm going to Fort Wayne make sure
he's better when I get back right that's
your job that's very interesting you say
that I'm gonna take a warm hand to your
face he's not better daddy daddy fell
asleep on the couch accidentally on
purpose upstairs
daddy fell asleep on the couch accident
because baby was hacking up along
and I knew I was gonna sleep because
that kid cries I wake up right away so
so now upstairs then I have a dream I
have a [ __ ] nightmare and my
nightmares my other kids I can't see
them but an hour a week I have this
dream we're in Ukraine and they can only
come out and play for one hour at night
to the bombshell yeah and I woke up
because I could and I was trying to keep
my daughter calm she's 14 my son's 11.
and I was I woke up with so much anxiety
I hate that you wake up with so much
anxiety because people are going through
terrible things like that was keeping
people from their children I know or
whatever you know it's got dark yeah I
know I know I but your kids make you so
fragile I'm such a [ __ ] scared of
everything I never used to be afraid I'm
afraid of everything now because of my
children I know [ __ ]
so I gotta I gotta I gotta skip town
yeah so I have to deal with it see ya I
gambled some parents are like I can't
and they just run away some dads what a
real piece of [ __ ] I got no time for
that I got no time for that that's I'm
unforgiving with that I have to be yeah
I wish you were in town long because
John annik is in uh tonight [ __ ] I
wanted to have my final kid for this
food truck well look my flight might get
canceled
I've only done a podcast with them I've
never met him in person great guy yeah
yeah smart yeah so they grounded all
flights last night yeah
according to Barstool they said all
flights but then bar stool but then uh
when I looked at this well no it's back
now last night they did the ground all
fights
hmm
okay what do we got dude okay I don't
want this flowerhorn to go
oh that was the first one
um did you guys watch the Golden Globes
last night I actually did so I'm so
happy that Gerard Carmichael yeah who I
love who opened for me and Dove back in
the day brought him a car I I did buy
them yes I I wasn't going to say that
but but but I bought him a car because I
believed him in him so much and I loved
him so much I could have used the
Shadows going Globes okay yeah he was so
special and so wonderful and I remember
I said to Deb I go I can't have this kid
taking the bus this kid is very special
his comedy was so gutsy and funny back
then hey what's it what's up I can't
believe he's hosting what's the Shelley
reference I know people were kind of
upset about that is the wife of the
leader of Scientology that went missing
in 2017. she can't find him
look man he's a beautiful soul and I
love that kid no one no one had a better
joke than Eddie Murphy so you can give
him whatever the like Entertainer of the
decade or whatever he gets up there you
have it yeah I just play it I just
played audio yeah wait who said this
Eddie Murphy
Eddie Murphy was up there did he win a
Golden Globe uh he won like uh
Entertainer of the Year or whatever you
know how they do the the Entertainer but
whatever like a lifetime of the day yeah
Lifetime Achievement okay I want to let
you know that there is a a definitive
blueprint
that you can follow
to achieve success
prosperity
longevity of mine
it's a blueprint and I followed it my
whole career it's very simple there's
three things you just do these three
things
pay your taxes
mind your business
and keep Will Smith's wife's name
foreign
[Applause]
and then the girl the Yellowstone won
some and then my boy from uh the Dahmer
series on Netflix one he's my favorite
for American Horror Story did it
attribute to uh Ryan Murphy who writes
all the American Horror Stories he's my
favorite he's a genie I just finished
all 11 Seasons it's my favorite series
of all time he's [ __ ] just incredible
the lassos if you're not comfortable
with gay scenes not for you
Ryan Murphy's
oh this you'd have to be with this last
series he's a genius God
yeah he is sandwich you guys I don't I
don't watch the series but that uh that
new Game of Thrones series whatever I
guess this girl that won the TV series
of the she's the the dragon Queen she
was hammered on stage yeah
I mean not too crazy but it just became
a viral thing but I guess the someone
was up with the food so they just gave
him drink so there's a lot of people
wasted she's gorgeous yeah
she's the actual Dragon what's in her
mouth
she just hammered she's so cute yeah
good for her
alrighty you you didn't you watch House
of dragons I did I haven't finished it I
need to some thoughts it's been out for
a scale of one to ten right up to the
Game of Thrones especially season one
okay so you don't have to build all the
characters backstory stuff so Game of
Thrones season one's a little slow this
yeah I thought this season one was
better than Game of Thrones season one I
found insane a lot yeah there's a lot of
setup so I I met I met let's pay off for
it Daddy okay all right all right
all right this is back to Dana Watson
update California women's caucus like I
said it's a total like 17 senators and
yeah wait are those the women Brian was
talking about that run California you
don't want them on your cake I don't
know if it's them is it them no it's the
California legislative women's caucus
it's probably some well I have the
California Lakeside women's caucus merch
is that the same
people I mean I I bought the hoodie I
mean I mean but so yeah 17 state
senators and 32 State Assembly women
um they're asking Endeavor and um our
Emmanuel to fire Dana White because of
himself what about her why haven't they
mentioned his wife she hit him first but
she's not the president of the UFC okay
so should they should be what should
happen to him well she's gonna lose her
Skinny Tea uh endorsement on Instagram
she lost that
really easy no I don't know
uh but they're just calling for because
there has been no um there's no
statements how do you see Dana White did
a press conference today I guess
apparently did President was like for
the fire sticking up for me don't it's
never acceptable he said quit sticking
up for me yeah he's like I don't need
you to stick up for me that's what I'm
saying from the jump don't let him deal
with this Fighters you're not getting
that's your bonus none of that [ __ ] this
is never okay right you don't need to go
that's that's correct let him eat his
Crow yeah deal with it yeah I don't
think he should lose his job there
should be some repercussions there has
to be you can't hit a woman in public
like that yeah maybe especially or
something I don't know I spent them for
what two pay-per-views or something I
don't know what you do I don't know what
you do there yeah I mean that but you
got the women's they'd like him to be
killed you're the women's college I
don't really want to take I don't know
the women's cockas on your case yeah I
have no idea but I'm not you know that's
probably a radical group of people in
one way or another there are groups of
people whoever they might be that are
not interested in anything but
destruction no they want you on the
street yeah they want you and he has
kids you know they were just daughter no
they want you to have kids yeah there's
plenty of that so I I don't know
hey here's the other thing people make
mistakes yeah and especially in marriage
that's a that's you know that that's
never hit I would say this they seem to
be oh hit Brian right now they seem to
be married back together they raised
kids together since they were 12. you
know so
um
they should make it okay there should be
summary repercussions there what I don't
know they seem to hit each other but
then I'm saying they seem to hit each
other you want to be their leveling
that's I don't know what it is but they
seem to they seem to settle their
disputes with some fisticuffs and um
that would be on her and him and that's
between them right now
I don't know why the caucus didn't
mention the the woman if they're in for
equal rights I didn't see if they
mentioned it or not but I'm sure they
probably didn't do it don't give me
stuff so with the whole day thing it's
even people are more upset because like
he returned to business like nothing
happened just like his [ __ ] Friday he
did one of those then he also did I came
up with that marketing chin vouch yeah I
came up with [ __ ] Friday really he
runs with it now yeah Mary was firing
all the people yeah I said oh Daniel
woke up was like oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it
Wednesday oh yeah I remember that two
months later it's [ __ ] it Friday and I
was hashtag [ __ ] friend I'm like oh
that's great you just changed it's
hilarious
um yeah so yeah so you know damage came
back like nothing happened but we all
saw we're living in a time a different
time with social media with cameras and
everything uh where everybody is is when
you do something you that that is
something like that that the reality is
everybody's gonna have a point of view
on it and there's going to be a [ __ ]
load of pressure on you and you could
lose your whole life when you are
behaving that way in public and just
know that and by the way the
consequences will be permanent they will
be extreme in the and and and so you
again you can you can have a life you
can live an exemplary life you can
[ __ ] you can somebody can say
something about you from 23 years ago
you can lose your entire career and it
will never come back so that's unless
you have a good partner in crime who
helped carries that's just the way it is
so with that said we do know people that
have been going through stuff that are
their cues or whatever but there's no
you know this is on film it's 100 this
one happened so that's what people with
the people that are accused they should
what I'm saying they should come back
right away and be like hey you know I
didn't do [ __ ] and just do regular shows
and nowadays when it's on film boy
that's a whole but it's on film he did
something wrong F's about about it yeah
and if butts about it like this is what
happened
um Jamal Hill wrote an article on it
saying you know basically she always
points towards racism she's like the
only reason he's not suffering any
consequences he's a white male I'm like
you don't know the sport that well right
now Dana White yeah the white male thing
different he's too famous
but that's powerful as [ __ ] he's so
powerful and also
I again I don't think you know the sport
and how powerful he is when you just say
oh it's a white male thing it's
definitely not because it can be a worse
time being a white male in America like
if anything that's working against him
right now yeah we would yeah let's start
what else do you got I will kill you
right now bro what I'll hit you okay
y'all get canceled if I beat you up I'll
stick my finger and I'll stick my dirty
fingers in your cage
I'll give your no patience
stupid you say shut up
holy [ __ ] you're getting it now today
I'm leaving here you're going to buy a
flower you've been here going to buy
that flower horn for 200 is your is your
tank primed and ready
primed it this morning who are you
putting the flowerhorn in with
uh put them in with a Jack Dempsey who's
larger uh uh a jaguar cichlid and a
Jaguar don't say Jaguar Jaguar no well
it's fish talked and then I'm doing two
uh Oscars in there
everyone else yeah I'm bored already
everyone else conversation everyone else
you got to get out yeah you got because
I'm a murder a murder he'll murder them
he's gonna rough up the rest of them
there's a big there's a shot caller
coming in
Manson or Suge Knight call Shot Caller
call shots
shots up shot shot shot shot shot shot
shot
shot
shots shots welcome shots you should
cause the shots in the tank yeah shots
give me some more give me some more uh
this is a quick one because this is here
in California the so the floods I
thought I was like whatever it's not
that crazy of a deal but it's actually
is that Ellen's generous that's Ellen
DeGeneres's backyard or something like
that oh let me see that somewhere else
is she okay
no she just said there was like a
regular oh my God she's gonna get out of
there okay
her house in [ __ ] Santa Clarita the
40 million dollar house is she gonna be
okay yeah I didn't care about the Ellen
DeGeneres thing but the floods are
pretty down here is the horrible that's
crazy over 17 people died already but
people think LA's this it's not kidding
me no I've never seen more rain in my
life and if anybody tells me we need it
one more time I'm freaked the [ __ ] out
look at this
that's just Ellen we need
we need it it's supposed to pick up uh
next week all next week's supposed to
rain too wow due to my fight kisses
I think this is my bike's like this oh
yeah yeah I just don't well get too much
we've been dry for a long time yeah it's
up like 400 or 600 increase versus the
this time of year now here's the thing
about LA right you would think they
would have this procedure set up so we
could uh capitalize on the rain we don't
have the infrastructure so the it's
great for forest fires and other things
but as far as like giving the water that
we need and provide more water we don't
have the infrastructure for it so it
doesn't really matter oh oh really yeah
yeah all the runoff water we're [ __ ]
oh really yeah
at least we have our almonds what else
you got you
this is DeMar Hamlin's uh I guess his
his sayings which is did we win that was
like the first thing he said when he
woke up from the
I guess whatever
coma or whatever yeah the doctor said
that was the first words that really
come out I believe that and then he's
all said oh people are saying three is
back their team I guess right so he
trademarked both of those phrases and I
guess they already started selling
shirts wow for we did we win like right
like earlier this month when he's in the
hospital oh yeah so that works yeah like
super fast I think Bill's gonna win the
Super Bowl now yeah you give
professionals a like motivation on top
of just getting to the Super Bowl give
them motivational to play for this guy
because like being the bills really you
think that place a real factor in Pro
Sports big time really the plane for a
bit a bigger thing like Inspirations
throws inspiration that's that Holy
Ghost [ __ ] where you're like God guys on
our side yeah I don't don't say holy
ghost but yeah it sounds like a spirit
yeah sure if you believe in Jesus well
God is good God is good
that's interesting though because there
are a lot of religious people on that
team but not all of them and now
religion or not you're playing for this
dude I can see what can happen I got you
I'm not been against those boys that's
interesting they even said the shaw
bills jerseys sound like hotcakes what
else you got Jen what
I didn't know that yeah 400 you had a
cup of coffee with those guys
hold on I might get taller
article
so this guy right here I guess he was
able to get his legs I heard it's so
painful oh yeah it looks super painful
but then he was he grow he was able to
grow five inches like the second time
he's done it [ __ ] so a total of five
inches he was five two now he's five
seven
my God made a big for his impacting his
life it was not working might be his
five seven eight taller turkey's doing
all the hair some guy came up to me at
micro drop comedy club in San Diego he
was from Australia he goes he pulls out
of he goes look at this mate he was from
like Australia he was he went to hair of
Istanbul
got the best hair transplant I've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life I was like holy
[ __ ] don't be surprised if I go on a
vacation don't ask me where I've gone
don't be surprised I will come back with
a nice thick head of hair Cowboy said
it's fast too you can do it he did it
yeah that's how they did they paid him
to do it yeah I might go there get
myself a little hair transplant and you
know what you're a little taller I'm
getting a little taller now this says
it's painless the remote control is used
by a patient increase their height by
one millimeter a day after the surgery
in a process that is usually painless I
make four to six tiny small incisions
into the leg creating a window to gain
access to the hollow part of the bone
which is fun to drill into one
millimeter yeah insert a device that
responds to external remote control that
a patient will control at home how do
they make it oh so the bone grows
[Music]
maybe if you just do it little
increments then it just your bone just
forms around this is just the beginning
of what the [ __ ] we're gonna be dealing
with this is just the beginning
yeah yes I think so well I thought just
cut the the back
I don't know
I'm just I need longer arms so I have
better reaches for ankle picks and for
punching yeah go through that pain to do
that dude yeah
I mean
even if they had it like down to a
science where you could make your wiener
longer I just wouldn't go through the
pain
surgery is risky it may not work or
surgery I mean it's at a slight
appearance of increased length to The
non-erq Pianist but it's not usually but
does not change the actual length of the
penis and worst surgery can result in
complications get the [ __ ] out of here
if you have if you have a way to grow
tissue now you're going to be [ __ ]
now we'll get serious guys are going to
have the biggest dogs on the planet uh
everybody
it'd be fun mess around one well they
they they're they can grow an ear they
can grow an ear with the stem cells they
can I remember they might be able to
grow a dick eventually they can grow
esophagus their mouse was like huh it
was on his back yeah
I'm pretty sure mice who are going to
grow dicks on their uh well remember
some some I think the soldiers had their
wieners blown off remember they'd use
like your thumb okay dude use my middle
finger yeah I think that but yeah
they're they're going to grow dicks I
hope soon I was watching you know Mark
Bell Chris Bell the the weightlifting
guys
um he had a podcast and had some expert
on and I guess there's like there's a
good amount of information showing that
penis pumps can increase your width and
length to a certain degree like penis
pump it increases your body's in the
dawn us chin she's like no it's it's
science yeah yeah you pump it yeah we'll
find out a few months we'll find out
yeah we don't need that stuff God is
good am I right I hey
I told you am I right God is good I
guess
let's talk about Arenas
when I was a freshman in college I
thought my dick was always not big I
suck porn and I said that guy's dick is
big and my girlfriend said your dick is
just as big and then I had sex with a
woman who was older and she said what
are you talking about you have a great
dog it's just your way of bragging about
your wiener yeah that's how I like to
end a podcast now listen if you're
anywhere close to Indiana this Friday
Saturday you might want to come and see
me hey Packer fans you guys are sad
right now because your team's on the
playoffs and you're losing Rogers to the
Niners or Broncos hopefully listen
if you're sad yeah go see Brian count
I'll make you laugh see that's a Fort
Wayne Indiana now here's the other thing
Dania Florida in Florida close to Miami
January 2021 the next weekend it's just
the next weekend then we got Evans in
Canada February 23 24 25. that's all
haven't been there in a long time
oh Edmonton that's where Grizzlies live
that's where polar bears are I mean not
around that mall yeah up north I'll see
um go get you some come on go see Brian
we're being sad I'm in Tampa Florida
next week next Friday Saturday Tampa Bay
improv Tampa Florida is next Friday and
Saturday that we will have 100 tiger
thick nectar available in person there
and all new on tour merch can only get
it in person as well that starts in
Tampa Florida next Friday Saturday
January 20th 21st Springfield Missouri
is February 3rd and 4th Naples February
16th through the 18th I'm gonna be
catching fish there Bakersfield
California one night only February 23rd
and then Brea is March 3rd and 4th right
now I'm gonna have to change that March
3rd day but for sure March 4th but March
3rd and 4th Brea as of now Oklahoma
City's on there as well but Tampa you're
up next week get you some at
thickboy.com or
fatkz.com I'm going to get this flower
horn I'll post it on my freaking yeah
all right kids is that it love you Brian
let's catch a plane love you guys